you look at the monsters of History  those have certainly been coming up a  lot recently you know the various  monstrous dictators of history from Mao  to Stalin to Hitler to all these people  they're all coming up what people do  realize that Mao and Stalin and Hitler  after they took power didn't actually  kill anyone right their State Police did  yeah if you have the building of a state  police that's loyal to only one party  within the borders of the United States  of America whether people realize it or  not there's nothing else that comes  close to the danger of that if the  Federal Bureau of the investigation is  now fully the enforcement arm of the  democratic party that that that trumps  inflation that trumps the border that  trumps taxes there's nothing else that  matters unless that is stopped that will  end the United States of America it will  they have the power to destroy anybody  already and that's only getting worse